get me Roger stone hello mr. stone good
morning gentlemen oh look enemy number
one well Roger we didn't know if you
were gonna talk to us or if you were
being worried about the gag order that
they're trying to put on you well we
don't know that yet the government has
not moved for a gag order they may do so
they expect them to do so sooner or
later but right now we are free to speak
my First Amendment rights are still
intact at least at this moment so Roger
what happened we're having a nice
conversation about a week ago we're
talking about you know Jim's making some
jokes about male ejaculate we're talking
about writing the best and worst dressed
list from jail all this fun stuff and
then not 24 hours after this
conversation Chad Ochocinco is on
Twitter and he's sitting there talking
about his neighbor Roger getting
bum-rushed by the FBI come to find out
they've like swatted your whole house
what happened twenty-nine FBI agents
with 17 vehicles including two armored
vehicles fully outfitted in Swat air
including night-vision goggles and
assault rifles as well as sidearms
surrounded my house too and fibia units
pulled up to my house on the canal
behind it
helicopter overhead they pounded on the
door at 5:50 a.m. I answered the door
wearing my Roger stone did nothing wrong
t-shirt which you can buy at 1776 dot
shop the money goes to my Legal Defense
Fund and a pair of cutoff sweat shorts
did you know that this was coming like
did you wear that t-shirt on purpose no
no I was actually sleeping in it that's
the irony CNN was told about my arrest
prior to my lawyers being told with my
arrest well they said it was just a
reporter's intuition which is why he was
there and it happened Iran events but if
I am dangerous why would they be allowed
to be 25 feet from the strip from the
front door the rest of the street was
sealed and cleared of everybody I think
that's gonna I'm glad to see Senator
Lindsey Graham looking into that
I think that will be disproved that they
were just operating on a hunch I look I
I don't own a firearm I don't have a
valid passport I'm not a flight risk I'm
charged with nonviolent processed crimes
I have no previous criminal record I'm
in my mid 60's all in pretty damn good
shape and they know that I'm represented
they could have contacted my lawyer and
I would have turned myself in so this
was a you know it's a purposeful show of
force they rousted my my wife they
marched her out in the street in a
nightgown and bare feet
she's hearing-impaired
I was concerned that they would think
she wasn't complying with an instruction
and shooter I mean the whole that my
dogs are terrified this whole thing was
unnecessary were you scared Roger um you
know I was relatively calm it was later
that it kind of hit me but the idea is
to poison the jury pool the idea is to
make me look guilty before I've gone to
trial they treat me you know like a drug
kingpin they they used more men to
arrest me than they used to say they
didn't kill bin Laden did you like now
that you've been arrested you weren't
sure if you're gonna be I know on some
level you suspected it but has that
changed your thinking now that you've
actually physically been arrested hasn't
changed my thinking whatsoever I pleaded
not guilty in court on Tuesday and I
will fight the charges I expect to be
acquitted and vindicated I think the
government's conduct to date has been
egregious I'll leave it at that and now
what is the president's idea hasn't said
a thing I've been spoken to the
president he has made some public
comments I think he is also shocked at
the force that was unnecessarily used do
you think if you had I do not disturb
sign on your door they would have turned
around I think it is highly unlikely
they had one of those big battering ram
things they were prepared to break the
door down if necessary but if beware of
dog sign Yorkie be a dangerous George I
am a [ __ ] Yorkie they're useless DUI
what about these text messages Roger I
was I was watching your interview and
one of these things we
talk to you all these times and you keep
telling us there's no this there's no
that there's no this but I saw him
there's a text from this guy Randy
credit Co and he's talking to you about
information that's gonna come out about
Hillary Clinton now this is the the idea
here is that there if he's texting you
this whether it's true or not at the
time you did have information that you
weren't supposed to have there are no no
okay
and I gave that text message to the to
the to the special counsels office and I
testified about it in my testimony in
September I've always said that he was
my source he lied about it before the
grand jury I produced email text
messages that pardon me
text messages that definitively prove it
it is entirely consistent with my
testimony I see I see but what I mean
you there are there are text messages
that you're now saying you forgot about
yes they're exculpatory they prove that
everything I told the committee was
accurate do you regret for I mean do you
do you kind of take yourself for being
like I went the interview after
interview after I have one no because I
have 1 million email I released those
text messages two months ago and I
turned them over to the special counsels
office they they prove that I told the
truth to the committee it is not illegal
to get information I never knew and was
never told the source or the content of
any of the material published by
WikiLeaks either that which was
allegedly hacked or that which was
allegedly stolen and I'm not charged
with that I'm not charged with
conspiracy
I'm not charged with collaborating with
looking leaks and receiving stolen
material I'm not charged with any crime
in connection with 26 election these are
all after the fact process crimes it's
essentially a frame-up because I support
Donald Trump for president what exactly
were you charged with charged with the
false statements before Congress witness
tampering and a feeding a and impeding
an official investigation so even if
even if you're innocent it's gonna cost
you what a half a million dollars from
right outside a farm or it's gonna cost
about two million so I ask people
stolen Defense Fund comm were you bummed
out that the Nixon family and the Nixon
estate distance themselves from you
you're such a fan you got Nixon tattooed
on your back you're putting the Nixon
peace signs up while all your supporters
were cheering for you I think the Nixon
foundation put distance between the
president people who never met Richard
Nixon ask ed Cox his son-in-law ask
Howell Raines the former editor of the
New York Times who I introduced the
former president to ask Monica Crowley
who was his aide in his post
presidential years about my relationship
with Richard Nixon doing Google search
under Roger stone Richard Nixon Saddle
River see what you say is it is it bad
for your personal morale when you're
going okay you know all these people are
here I need to talk to the people about
what happened you're just out on bail
you put the 250 you got the $250,000
bail bond you got out of there and you
go and you do this perfectly clear I
didn't have to put up anything I'm not a
flight risk
is that a $250 $50,000 turkey bond that
means I put up no money I signed out my
signature which the government agreed to
that's what happens when you are not a
flight risk but when you go out there
and you do this press conference and
you're going this is ridiculous blah
blah blah and everybody is chanting boo
and lock him up are you going come on
guys I don't wanna have to deal with
this right now I mean there were four
cameras and microphones outside the Fort
Lauderdale courthouse I wanted to make a
statement to say that I was not guilty
and would plead not guilty I couldn't
make the statement because the torrent
of spit and pushing and shoving and
yelling I felt like Vice President
Richard Nixon in Caracas in 1958 I mean
it was it was crazy what did you think
of Jake Tapper's comment that you might
like prison I mean everybody knows what
he was kind of implying beneath a bell I
think that was that was a low blow and
he's a guy to look light in the loafers
to me she says so your response to him
is uh
you're not gay he is if he apologizes
apologist to the LGBT community then
shouldn't you also apologize to them for
just calling him light in the loafers
isn't it kind of the same thing he I say
okay that is true you're just trying to
commenting and denying and saying that
he is indeed looking more homosexual
[Laughter]
well actually it's funny that you bring
up yes I wanted to ask you about that
what didn't you like that you've tried
it's interesting that the Daily Mail
decided to Drudge up the the old reports
from the I think from the National
Enquirer about you and your swinging sex
life they wrote a whole article about
that article all the information that
already been out for a long nothing new
but it was entertaining to read again if
you were to if you were to look for
people and if you were to look for
people now do you still have a policy of
no fats consenting activities among
adults are their own business next
question and so no fats then next
question okay eight inches is that true
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's our sanam are you so now that
this is real right now that there there
actually is a case not to say that like
you're guilty or anything but we're now
several degrees more into this than we
were the last time we spoke is there
part of you that is finally going holy
[ __ ]
regardless of what I what I'm saying
what regardless of what the truth is
regardless of how I'm feeling there is
this possibility now that this ends up
bad there is this version of the way
this goes where I end up in jail
seriously be in prison for forty five
years under these charges that's why I
won't fight them and I need people to
help me fight to by going stone Defense
Fund calm I have not broken any laws he
said this is a fabricated chart for a
political vendetta I've supported Donna
for president I opposed Hillary Clinton
that's why I am being tart where's the
Russian collusion where's the WikiLeaks
collaboration where's the conspiracy
doesn't exist do you think that they're
just doing this to try to get you to
talk about trumpet they're trying to
frighten you into turning on the
president that very well maybe I think
I've made it pretty clear that I will
not bear false witness against the
president when I said on ABC I would
answer all questions honestly
they said dome will cooperate with the
special counsel well I will answer all
questions honestly that's what I will do
and you said you never talked about a
pardon with him but did he did he ever
hint at it no absolutely not
so when you when when the FBI comes in
what was your mentality were you
thinking like oh my god I can't believe
this is happening or was it one of those
sort of movie scenes where you're going
yeah I kind of knew that this was going
to go down at some point I guess today's
the day yeah is that why you slept with
Roger stone did nothing wrong shirt I
really did expect them to do what
normally is done in these cases which is
to contact my lawyer and I would have
been allowed to turn myself in and I
would have worn a suit and tie and
looked a hell of a lot better in my mug
shot but my my initial concern frankly
was they would not realize my wife is
deaf I think she wasn't complying with
an ordering sugar yeah yeah I mean I'd
be scared too well you was there any
part of you that goes like when you talk
about clothes when you saw after the
press conference you put your arms up
and you did the Richard Nixon piece
signs were you thinking to yourself like
I got to start getting longer shirts
well the FBI agents were actually quite
courteous once I was in custody they
allowed me to change my clothes put on
long pants and a pair of shoes and a
better shirt but you know that photo
fortunately he can be prompt now were
you surprised I think you surprised
people were booing you and that you
didn't have more fans outside I was
surprised to hear than bullying you to
be honest I live in one of the most
liberal Democratic counties in the state
of Florida most liberal democratic Perry
and I had many supporters out there as I
did have outside the courthouse in DC on
the other hand I'm not interested in
being Jack Ruby down the street right
right now what is your relationship with
Ochocinco do you guys talk a lot
I know he's a neighbor I don't really
know him I'm told it was great Ashley he
was but he was surprised because on
Twitter on Twitter he just referred to
you as his neighbor rod yeah like he
seemed to have no idea any of this was
going on he really didn't have a yeah I
mean look I'm not betting this probably
not that into politics but anybody who
knows me knows that I have argued
against the 1994 crime bill and the UH
the unfair and racist disparity in
sentencing between four people and black
people and rich white people and that
I've talked about this for 15 years I've
spoken out for a posthumous pardon for
Marcus Garvey I have argued in favor of
affirmative action which is a Nixon
policy that is very unpopular with many
conservatives but which I strongly
support so why Marcus Garvey what was he
what did he what he was he convicted
under you think he's at the FBI
railroaded him that's why they
completely and totally railroaded and he
scared the white power establishment
because he was an early and very
effective civil rights leader are you
worried about being railroaded at all I
mean I mean it's harder for it to happen
now but are you worried about that yes I
am yeah I mean you hear horror stories
sure I'm like that's what that's what I
mean like that's where I asked the
question before because once you get
arrested and there's charges and
everything you can be innocent you can
have the best defense ever it's just
it's it it's up in the air what do you
do you I do you know what the plan is
have you talked to your lawyer about
what the plan is if a gag order comes
down what you'll do with that no and I
don't want to address it now I haven't
discussed it with my lawyers obviously
we would most likely appeal it remember
I make my living writing and talking
that's what I do for a living if I
cannot write and talk about politics
then I can't put food on my family's
table things are bad enough as you know
like as I told you last week I've I've
essentially broke I've lost my life and
health insurance that's you sell my car
my income is the window because of the
constant leaking from the special
counsel's office
so it would be unfair the jugs could of
course order that I can't speak about
this case but it all pine on general
politics I don't know it's a
hypothetical question we'll address it
you know if and when it happened who do
you think is all is leaking everything
out of the White House people are saying
it's Kellyanne Conway I have no idea you
asked me that last week I really don't
know yeah I thought maybe had heard
something since then I don't think
they're talking to him right now
no no why not they probably want to keep
Roger on their good side but I mean do
you think they're concerned that what
happened with Michael Cohen will happen
with you that they kind of cut him off
and all of a sudden he turns around and
starts saying things they don't want to
say I've been made very clear that I
will not make up stories about the
president I will not bear false witness
about the president I don't know of any
inappropriate activity by the president
I'm not going to perjure myself and make
stuff up this is what I think Michael
Cohen has done so you don't think that
there there are no in your head
there are knows true stories that you
might end up telling that would be less
than Pleasant for the president that is
correct
okay okay what do you think it is about
Trump that people hate so much do they
hate him more than I hated Bush they
hate him well they hated Obama well what
do you what do you think it is about him
that just gets this visceral reaction
from people because he because he
challenges the two-party duopoly and the
elites of both parties he challenges the
status quo he has his own inimitable but
eccentric style but we have a boom
economy we have four point eight million
new jobs
we have 500,000 new manufacturing jobs
we're redoing these lousy trade deals
that screwed us
we are not dishing out billions of
dollars to the Iranians so they can turn
around and screw us he's getting things
done in his own way yeah but these are
these are all these are all economical
what about the racial divide in this
country the anti-semitism in he's but
yes he's the one who signed a prison
reform bill what is the fact that that
black and poor people are
disproportionately what sentence day
women is it the lowest point when those
people when those when those people were
shot in the synagogue in Pittsburgh he
didn't
denounce white supremacy he didn't
announce it in Charlottesville okay so
he don't actually he's not adding to you
know even if it's some subliminal or
through the backdoor he's adding hatred
towards people do you I don't see that I
disagree with that
all right gentlemen this has been absurd
but I gotta move along all right right
okay well thank you very much welcome
you and we appreciate you you calling in
you know we we appreciate you doing that
and your website is stone-cold true calm
and where can people find the Roger
stone Defense Fund stone Defense Fund
calm
thank you Jim thank you say I'm
appreciate